hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to goat simulator the update
there's a whole new level and a whole
new bunch of stuff to discover so let's
get into it
there's no time to waste now as you know
I played quite a few episodes of goat
simulator but there's a lot of new
content added but in the beginning I'm
just gonna be exploring the new end here
the area so let's get into it
yep alright goodbye everybody I'm gonna
go into the ocean Thank You max is that
a club may I join oh why are you looking
at me like that
don't look at me yeah that's right
you've had a run let me in Max's matter
thank you your name is still not line
it's Bonnie hope you know hey hey come
on don't be like that there we go thank
you for being cooperative I'm just gonna
scoot on the boat what are you guys
doing over here
guys having a fun party without me the
axes okay ragdoll good whoa
but they didn't go anywhere two tickets
please thank you wants to be my date
goodbye so much fun in my entire life
hello nice crotch why did you fall over
what's your Excuse hello Bonnie
okay I'm kind of sorry about that don't
know how to fix your problem there but
just sit tight um I'm sure paramedics
will be on the way okay you're fine get
out of here oh is this a buckin Punk oh
oh okay I don't know why that happened
but so thank you Thank You Bonnie
now we can be together forever I really
don't know what the hell's is a veneer
buddy you're having such a magical
adventure thank you for joining me you
finally discovered my love
oh no aren't you jealous of me and my
Bonnie that's right back off here's out
here Bonnie would you like to go in the
bouncy castle all right buddy
okay now gonna bake it oh can I have
some snacks please my dad Pawnee is very
hungry
thank you buddy I got you something no
booty oh hey what's happened to you so I
get you back on me Pawnee
she's dead
she seems she's not even ragdoll that's
how dead she is bonnie bonnie you don't
seem to be doing so well she's just
gonna start rolling over and okay Bonnie
you won't even talk to me I don't want
to see you in this mood bonnie bonnie
bonnie really can't even look at me
Bonnie whatever Bonnie you never liked
me anyway yeah you throw that tantrum
both the ground you flail over there Oh
goodbye oh I can push this yeah oh god
how did I hear about that bears well
okay just gonna go why why why what is
going on with you why Bonnie
Stuart I'm a goat I'm go go go go go go
go - go go go go go okay I want to ride
oh look it's another Golden Goose II
booth okay so I need to collect more of
those basically what you're saying thank
you come on let me in let me in let me
in following up my date here but I was
all by myself
milla milla man I want in okay am I
strapped how do how do i I don't make
sure that I stay well this is about as
secure as I can imagine myself so much
fine I can't imagine you Oh God that's
always faster than I anticipated
Oh God this is a mistake okay
being slung shotted flanks yet a big
slack jawed everywhere knows a lot of
fun can I stop now hurts my brains
brains bigger right now okay thank you
thank you goodbye oh it was perfect time
yeah Oh goddamn it dings damn it oh yes
oh no okay half yourself in the a oh
come on damn it damn it up the ass in
the a-hole whoa there we go got it yes
yes yes yes yes I was hoping that that'd
be one of these up here I did it I did
it I'm gonna get the other goats cuz
there's no ghost or Paco okay that was
not the lead parkour that I was hoping
it was gonna be that was actually very
pathetic actually ha ha ha ha oh god
that was cool I did it oh I kind of did
it me parkour oh oh you up to bye I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna do it to it oh yes
I did it did it to it oh damn it damn it
I was so close oh I could have made it
up there easily yes yes
I believe in you goats you guys really
gives it to him you guys have to live
with the goods you gotta be willing to
sacrifice everything for success god
damn it I said success not suck ass oh I
got it that's for I got it you [ __ ] you
think you're gonna escape from me I am
the king of the walls on now not many
people know but I'm actually good at
games don't know why I need to keep
saying that people don't believe me look
what's appear this is something of value
that I need
well what the hell good is that it's
it's a ramp into death why would I jump
off of there hello you might be
something I need well I know I need to
jump off of there now come back you mr.
helicopter I'm going to get you where
you going come back you're the only way
to get to the top of that building
aren't you well then we're just gonna
keep doing this until I get to there
you're gonna let me up there mister man
get back down here you [ __ ] hey stupid
ass get your helicopter down here you're
such a douchebag yeah that's right I'm
talking to you
the worst helicopter pilot in the war
are old Oh
it's Mike ok so my time yeah he's gonna
circle around I'll be able to jump up as
soon as he comes back next time he's
coming he's coming he's coming oh my god
this is it oh god I mean already oh oh
oh my god oh my god I'm ready I'm ready
I'm ready for it I'm ready go go go go
god yes I got it
whoa you can pass me on buildings all
you want but I'll never let go I've got
the tongue of Steel I've got the tongue
strong it's fine okay it's okay it's
okay it's okay
cuz it's gonna calm down gonna let go
but can you stop could you stop oh god I
want to get down stop
what are you doing what are you doing
stop stop stop
telegram she's gonna boom oh god oh god
I thought I didn't make that okay just
calm down calm your tits no no no just
counteracted counteracted counteracted
goes in the opposite direction of the
swing and swinging okay you are the
biggest [ __ ] I have ever met in my
entire life I hate you so much
I want to strangle you but I'm gonna get
up there because there's nothing you can
say that will stop me from getting to my
goal okay calm calm calm calm calm
please oh my god oh that was my moment I
should have done that yes yes that was
totally worth it and definitely not a
waste of my time who doesn't respect my
goat but anybody want to get my goats
ass got to take it up with deadmau5 here
it's deadmau5 gonna be my new bunny does
he even want to be my new Barney I don't
think he has much of a choice at this
point
kind of oh my god I am so sorry let me
make it up to you okay
dancing it's not the life for me that's
why I sit in a chair
here have a deadness whoa whoa what's
happening whoa whoa whoa whoa no I want
up there
no come on something cool is up there I
want it damn it you son of a [ __ ]
okay whoa wait a minute wait a minute
it's down here oh my god oh my god what
is that oh my god what the hell was that
all right so that was the updated goat
simulator there was a lot of stuff at it
and I haven't even scratched the surface
so if you enjoyed this video please
click the like button down below and let
me know if you want more in the comments
thanks again everybody for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video
ah